hallo mein name ist nur hier ist drin
und wir suchen heute mal wieder was beim
akinator wenn uns letzten spiele so
anschauen sehen wir luca luka
schaut euch mal bitte den trend hier
vorne an chantal
konkret das zebra gefordert sind gerade
nur vitali der politik bald auch blieb
am 12 gibt es denn da bei lewis gerade
das aufkommen der compact die tür hier
rein machen wir wieder zurück lange aber
jetzt jetzt kommen wir uns herum kommen
hier um kommen wir hier rum kann man
hier
hi
der war gerade einkaufen ballouz jetzt
auch hier den können wir mal auch hier
vorderen wieder und jetzt schauen wir
doch einfach mal mit martina tor was wir
denn alles so finden können mir wurde
häufig in die kommentare geschrieben das
meint opel eingereicht wurde
testen weil jetzt mache ja sie wurde
durch youtube berühmt nein die tri keine
männerkleidung nein sie hat nicht fürs
zdf gearbeitet 9 ist nicht größer als
ein metallgitter die figur leadgitarrist
einer deutschen hard rock band
ich glaube nicht nein meine figur keine
beine machen sie kamen nicht aus einem
kollegen geschäft nach hinten aber keine
flasche alter wir direkt denkt das ist
ein kollege oder wie krank ist das denn
ein der nichts mit dem schwarm zu tun
nein sie ist kein fisch
liegt der die figur auf dem schreibtisch
beckers ich sage mal wahrscheinlich wer
hat da mein café tuch eingereicht
das ist jetzt nicht euer ernst ich habe
die tage in einem video gesagt dass sich
ein tuch hatte womit ich kaffee
aufgemischt hatte und jetzt habe ich
hier ein taschentuch womit ich den
pick-up weg gemacht habe und das sollte
nicht bei akinator einkommen das ist
doch auch wieder gleich bei akinator das
kann doch nicht sein aber ich sag mal
dass es das ist und dass
wollt ihr mich verarschen mir kommt so
vor als ob alles was sich irgendwie
anfasse in akinator reinkommt
es ist nicht wahr aber wir versuchen
jetzt einfach mal noch mal meint opel zu
finden
frage nummer zwei ist deine figur im
besitz von crafter hawking aging nia ist
sie nein die hat kein tierisches
aussehen nein sie kommen nicht aus dem
all ihren geschäften ein wie keine
flasche ja sie passt in eine flasche
liegt eine figur zum ports und im hilfen
job bei
tun dass pope gesundheit popel essen
steckt das im urlaub bin raus jetzt gibt
tatsächlich eine website die popel punkt
info heißt da findet man alles über
popel informationen wissenswertes und
lustig ist mit den ganzen popeln was man
jeder darüber lernen kamen
das ist doch unfair
haben popel noch andere namen joachim
löw beim nasebohren erwischt wir gehen
mal wieder zurück war die nato ich sag
mal ich weiß nicht ob das so
wissenschaft beiträgt meine figur ist
ein popel weiß eigentlich sind ich sag
mal wahrscheinlich ist deine figur
kirchen nein es sollte für becker ist
dann eine spielfigur clash of client
nein hatte eine weiße haut nein kann
eine figur der luft schweben nein lebt
auf das zimmer ja deine für einen
geschickten nein dass die begrüßung
werden nach figur moin ich glaube mein
nein wird deine figur von luca komma
contractor gespielt
nein nein meine frau arbeitet nicht in
deutschland nein wird keine kanten
da hat tatsächlich jemand meinen parking
mein gott ich denke an konkret dass opel
ein koloss contractors nase ja es ist
mein problem meint opel wurde tausend
mal gespielt
1000 leute haben meinen popo gespielt
gemäss witze ich klicke jetzt einfach
mal auf ein foto ein ra
das foto zu dieser figur ist derzeit in
bearbeitung ein download ist daher nicht
möglich ich kann jetzt kein foto für
meinen eigenen popel einreichen ich habe
gerade extra hier so ein schönes foto
aufgenommen ich bin gerade wieder auf
der startseite von hakin ator und was
sehe ich es wurde ball gespielt es wurde
ukulele gespielt und es wurde luca
gespielt luca gespielt locker gespielt
wir sind fünf der letzten zehn
gespielten spiele datei 50 prozent der
website gehört mir liebe entwickler wenn
ihr die website irgendwann mal verkaufen
wollte
ich will mich ich würde die nehmen wir
machen jetzt mal eine runde die ich so
noch nie gemacht habe frage nummer eins
gehört deine figur korn crafter die
erste frage
oh mein gott ich möchte jetzt einfach
ganz viele fragen immer abwechseln mit
ja und nein beantworten und dann einfach
mal zu sehen was da hinten rauskommt das
heißt ich werde jetzt in einem pfad
durch lagern weil ich schon weiß dass
der
ich denke an ein typ der immer zockt ein
kluger typ der zufällig antwortet ja das
bin ich der wurde eine million mal
gespielt eine million hier wurde letztes
gesagt dass ich auch schon an den
250.000 mal gespielt wurde das werde ich
dann am nächsten mal nach decken aber
jetzt ist dieses video erst mal vorbei